hello everyone and welcome to a video
where I will spoil the result of the
game or rather games in front of
everything else I will spoil it before
even showing you the moves so for those
of you who are not interested in that
skip 30 seconds and only then continue
watching the video now what is being
Happening Here have been happening uh it
is the the best day in the life of Lavon
arunanist he defeated both Magnus
Carlsen and diani punish in two
consecutive rounds and you guys started
requesting it I will show the game
against Magnus and the end of the game
against nepo as it's uh well it's pretty
much a snoozefest but the end is very
nice so let's dive straight into it and
now for those of you who skipped to this
part uh let's check out the game slash
games so Magnus has the white pieces and
he opens with Pawn to B3 he goes for the
names of Larson attack or the cowboy
opening as it's being called nowadays
Ponte D5 at the the classical variation
to the to the Cowboy attack Bishop to B2
Knight F6 Knight to F3 and now there are
some uh different ways you could treat
this E6 is the most popular movie or you
could play C5 you could play Bishop 501
goes for Bishop to G4 this is only the
fourth most popular continuation so
obviously he knows uh how he wants the
catch Magnus uh uh you know uh by
surprise we have E3 E6 with Ponte H3 and
he moves the bishop back Pawn to H5 Pawn
to D3 and now Pawn to H6 with Pawn to G4
and Bishop to G6 with Knight to E5
putting pressure on the bishop and
Bishop to H7 so nothing new here uh
there is a game where Bishop to G2 was
played but now we have Knights the D2
and it is now already as of move 9 that
we have a completely new game and what
more could we ask for uh in a game
between Magnus and Levon uh we have
Knight F to D7 immediately training of
the powerful knight and E5 and here at
Magnus trade with Knight captures Knight
captures and just Bishop to G2 Magnus
really slow pain slow playing this thing
Kettering both of the Bishops uh we have
bought the C6 creating a nice Center
here and the bishop now comes uh sorry
Queen comes to E2 preparing the castle
Queen side Queen to C7 Levon does the
same and now Pawn to F4 we have pawned
the F6 uh and now Castle's Queen side uh
sorry Castle screen size by white and
now Queen to A5 now Levon could also
Castle Queen side here but he first uh
goes after the A2 pawn and the Magnus
just leaves at B he goes Pawn to E4 and
indeed uh it would be very very
ill-advised to capture the pawn if you
capture the pawn then captures on D5 and
black is already close to lost you
cannot capture back of course because
the you are pinned if you play C
captures and D5 then Queen captures and
E6 uh it's not I mean it's it's just
really bad so instead after E4 we have
Castle's Queen side and now King to B1
just nicely guarding the pawn here uh
with Bishop to A3 of course going after
this um uh trade it's a very standard
setup where when you have this position
with the pawns and the theme cathode
Bishop you generally want to trade off
the bishop because then the there will
be dark Square weaknesses around the the
white king and if you can get your queen
let's say the A3 if this Knight somehow
finds his way all the way to B4 it's
pretty much game over so that's the plan
Bishop captures with Queen captures and
now e captures on D5 e captures on D5
and Rook H to E1 and now uh if you don't
want to see Pawn to F5 you have to play
Pawn to F5 yourself so that's exactly
what level one does uh Knight to F3 and
now F captures on G4 we have H captors
and now uh while you're probably
expecting Rook H the E8 the counter the
queen and the rook and the E file the
one plays Rook The Rook H the f8 uh and
okay Magnus plays Pawn to F5 the pawn is
hanging so you have to either defend it
or uh Advance it forward
our level in advance is it sorry Magnus
advances it and now Knight to F6 putting
pressure on the G4 pawn and uh here
Magnus plays Bishop to H3 it looks like
a funny Square for the bishop but the
idea is if the knight ever moves you
have a G5 F6 with some discoveries uh
could be it could be very nice uh also
if you don't want to do this you can
just play 95 it's a great Square for the
Knight also the G4 Pawn is defended but
the bishop remains on this well uh
diagonal of of questionable quality so
instead Bishop to H3 and now Pawn to D4
and this is a move you never want to see
when you have this setup with your
having kettled Bishop trade it off
because now you know the Knight is
coming to D5 to C3 and that's just the
game over now it is possible to defend
this but it is rapid chess like if you
play Queen to D2 everything is still
fine you can't go Knight to D5 because
Knight just captures and now the C3
squared is a square is covered by the
queen and also you cannot go Queen A5 to
cover the the C3 Square uh however in
the game on the G5 was played and now
comes H captors and G5 interestingly
Levon could go Knight to D5 right away
it's not straight out winning but it
will be very hard to defend you allow F6
check and after King the B8 Queen to E5
check you even allow this and after King
to A8 Queen captures on D4 and now the
queen is guarding the C3 square but it's
different the queen is not on D2 like in
the previous line that we've shown uh
where the A5 square is guarded so here
you can play Queen to a 5-0 Knights the
C3 check could be incredibly strong so
King to B2 stopping that and now Knight
to B4 and now the queen is attacked and
also the A2 pawn and this looks very
very promising for black for example
Queen C3 are gonna capture an A2 with
Chuck King to C1 Queen to eighth richer
King V1 other Knight comes back to D5
attacks the White Queen and it just uh
looks incredibly strong like I said it's
not probably winning by force but it
will be very hard to defend in Rapid but
okay 11 played H captures and G5 and
instead and now Knight captures on G5 by
Magnus Bishop to G8 and now Bishop to G2
and here you would probably expect the
best of G to move of course aimed at
guarding that D5 Square so you know that
if Knight comes to D5 you will just uh
you'll just trade this bishop for Knight
instantly uh no questions asked there
but Lavon played uh truly a Levon move
here this this is a level he played Rook
to D5 and now the problem is you know
that if you capture the Knight comes the
D5 if you don't capture The Rook comes
to A5 and you get checkmated so how do
you even approach uh uh you know to
defending this there are a couple of
ways you could play something like Pawn
to C4 or even Pawn to C3 which simply
opens up uh the path for the queen to
help out with the defense of the white
king but there's a much better way if
Magnus spotted Queen to E7 he attacks
The Rook he attacks the queen uh you
have to trade Queens here and then it's
uh I mean you just play play the same
game so no no harm there but Magnus
played Bishop captures on D5 and 11 just
play Knight captures on D5 and it was in
this position and move 27 that Magnus
Carlsen resigned to the game as now
there is nothing more
um to be done here there is no way to
defend the Knight is coming to C3 and
that's just it okay you could maybe uh
survive for a little bit longer I mean
if you do nothing of course tonight the
C3 check is Just Deadly uh let's say you
play some sort of a Moon Knight that he
says just Knight the C3 check King to A1
and queen captures and A2 will be
Checkmate so you can't just play any
move uh you have to play something like
C4 at least the queen now covers the A2
square but still Knights the C3 check
King will move and then uh you lose the
queen so I mean it's uh it's just
unplayable so very weird for Magnus to
do this maybe he was I have no idea what
he was uh uh trying to do with Bishop
captures on D5 maybe yeah I have no idea
it's just I I'm guessing it's just uh
you know a complete blind spot you know
a moment of
um uh you know of silliness uh but what
are you gonna do uh he captured it and
after the one captured back Magnus
resigned and just a very nice victory
for levonne arena and they weren't even
in time trouble they had like over a
minute on the clock I think uh but I
don't want to trick you guys I will
check uh so yeah in the end okay Magnus
said 28 seconds Lavon had 36 seconds but
it's still I mean for these guys this is
uh this is practically an eternity uh so
this is how Magnus defeated uh eleven
defeated Magnus Carson and then uh in
round 10 he played Yanni punishi and we
are only going to show a part of that
game uh this is the part against uh nepo
and this is the position here Levon had
the white pieces and uh uh here uh uh
just to show you here 11 played rooked
the C3 it's not not the the the absolute
best move but it's like as a rapid chest
and apple played Knight to B4 which
blunders material here here uh Lavon
just caught it with Rook to B3 now the
Knight is lost or if you move the Knight
The Rook is lost so the best you can do
is to trade Knight captures on C3 giving
up the exchange Rook captures on B5 and
now you have to play out this end game
where you're up the exchange and up a
pawn and of course Levon is too strong a
player not to win this I will just show
it for example King G4 King D2 Knight to
F2 Rook captures an E5 now Knight
captures and G2 and nipple also created
a pass Pawn but just Bishop capture
spawn captures and a king to E2 is the
only move that wins but it's not a
difficult one to spot because you are
threatening promotion so King E2 now
Knight to F4 with check and of course
you don't capture the pawn because
Knight the C3 wins The Rook so of course
King the F1 was played now Knights the
D3 attacks The Rook Rook to F5 and after
Knight captures on B2 King captures an
F2 now the pass Pawn is of course
completely winning 9 a C4 we have rooked
f8 and knocking the G5 with King to E2
King to G6 and now King to D3 Knight to
E5 with check King to D4 and he was in
this position I unmoved 75 that Yani
promise you resigned the game as there
is nothing more to be done here so a
really really impressive stuff uh uh
beating not just magnets but Magnus and
nipple in the same day uh in Rapid time
format so as far as rapid time format
goes this is probably probably the the
best day in the life of Levon arunian
and here you resign because well if you
go up the board doesn't really help if
you go down the board the only square is
pretty much G4 you can simply trade Rook
for Knight and that's it let the king H5
cappers capture spawn to E5 and the pawn
cannot be stopped of course you will try
it but there is no way of doing it King
F6 you will uh you know approach the
pawn here here here here and now you
just Advance the pawn and win the game
easily yeah after King to D4 uh 11 uh
level one another game for resigned and
that's how Levon defeated both Magnus
and nepo in the same day in Rapid time
format hope you enjoyed that story I
would like to thank g Meadow tool Yoon
Yang Federico Torres Velasco Dan
McCormick and James Eugene Cashman for
your contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check to all my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing to check up
on you one of the suggestions and
whatever else happens in the Chess World
so thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day and
as suggestions are coming in I think I
already know my next video it's also
from this tournament I heard that Wei Yi
played another will I'm not gonna say
it's an immortal but you guys you guys
are saying it's a really nice game so
probably that that one is coming up next
see you soon